Federal reserve's upcoming instant
payment service fed now will be
integrated with metal blockchain
allowing metal users to convert funds to
stablecoin and vice versa using the FED
now system send and receive function fed
now is set to launch in July and will
enable round-the-clock near instant
payments between Banks metal blockchain
developed by metallicious metal licus
offers compliance friendly options for
decentralized finance D5 developers and
emphasizes bank secure bank secrecy act
compliance Etc et cetera anyways I'll
give you the other story as well the
other story is Goldman Microsoft sibo
and others team up to launch
blockchain's Network this is a Bloomberg
story group of firms including Goldman
Sachs Microsoft the Lloyd sibo Global
markets is teaming up to launch the
Canton Network a blockchain system aimed
at linking institutional applications
and promoting wider adoption of
distributed Ledger techno technology and
financial markets the network offers
improved privacy and controls along with
scalability and standard suitable for
financial institutions what are your
thoughts on these two stories how do you
think the Market's going to respond to
this I think both of these stories are
on nothing burgers and I'll tell you why
I'll go through it so metal with all
respect to them known the company or the
protocols since since they launched back
in the day they launched an apparently
Richard Branson was one of the investors
and they've been looking for an identity
since and I think that this announcement
would impress me a lot more If the Fed
came out and the FED said hey we are now
we have picked this blockchain provider
so that's my response to the first story
I think it's a nothing Burger I think
regarding the Second Story
by definition blockchains are open
public ledgers otherwise they're just
glorified databases and they need to be
permissionless and not controlled by
anyone and and that is why Bitcoin has
been so successful and that's why
ethereum is the second most successful
because it's permissionless it's not
owned by anyone it's not controlled by
anyone it's not it's not um swayable by
anyone when you're talking about these
companies
these are exactly the companies that
blockchain is trying to move away from
them being controlled and so you know
you can make as many announcements as
you want but ultimately let's look at
who's going to be using your blockchain
and what they're going to be using your
blockchain for right now the most used
blockchain between I mean you have two
two blockchains which are really both
being used which are Bitcoin and
ethereum and the one thing that makes
them both that used is the fact that
none of these corporations are are able
to control it structure it fund it
Finance it they can use it as equal
players as if we use it and that's the
beauty of these things so I think it's
like this is both of these stories for
me aren't aren't really big stories I
think we'll hear about it here and I
don't think we'll ever hear about these
stories again to be honest yeah I mean I
don't follow the the crypto stuff the
Bitcoin stuff uh as much but I just look
at this from the standpoint of the
Central Bank digital currency which I
think is what most people really worried
about right when they read about fed now
and fed now is basically centralizing uh
the settlement process and the
Clearinghouse that right now is done by
a quasi-free market process so whenever
you have centralization or something
like that I don't like it but I also
want to highlight something that he was
saying and using the word Ledger because
people need to realize that that money
or let's say currency outside of green
pieces of paper really doesn't exist
all it is is a ledger system that says
hey the Bank owes you this much and so
it's like time you you really can't all
you can do is keep track of it right so
my point here is when people hear fed
now they get really freaked out about
Central Bank digital currency but they
shouldn't I I want to make sure the
people who value privacy Freedom Liberty
and free market capitalism focus more so
on The Ledger and less on the currency
as far as the Central Bank digital
currency because if and I think that
we're going into this tough time like we
talked about earlier and I think one of
the solutions that they're going to
provide so the depositors don't take a
haircut is to move your deposits to the
federal reserve's Ledger right and when
you move all of these deposits to The
fed's Ledger now you have that ledger
centralized including the back end
Plumbing which is fed now and that by
definition gives you a central bank
digital currency regardless of what they
call call it so right now when I see
Florida Banning Central Bank digital
currencies or I see Ted Cruz in Texas
doing the same thing I think that's
great that it's bringing attention but
I'm very concerned that the globally
leader using this as a diversionary
tactic because they're they're they're
starting this Central Bank digital
currency fire over here while at the
same time they're creating an
environment where you could centralize
that ledger and and people are so
focused on that Central Bank digital
currency they wake up in six months and
like how on Earth do I have a social
score because they don't realize that
the the fundamentals of a cbdc is moving
all those deposits onto one Ledger more
centralization and that's the first
thing that I think about when I see this
article so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign